you got caught okay you got God and okay
I think we should create a set of the
Forbes 30 to 30. I think we need like
the Madoff 1000
um we're all the grifters and con
artists that are that are out there
[Music]
all right we don't normally let Ben have
ideas but we let the man out of the cage
he's got an idea in bed what you you
texted us this morning you want to try
something what do you want to try we're
doing a new segment fellas we're just
gonna we're going quick through the news
and we're having you guys react people
want to know what the fellas think about
what's happening so we're gonna we're
gonna find out or call it I'm gonna call
this the boys react
I've been trying to make this the boys
thing a a thing for a little while now
and it hasn't happened
but as I taught my daughter yesterday we
never give up and so the boys react is
gonna be uh we're gonna react to the
news here so Ben you have some news
segments uh or new stories I guess and
um Sam Sam actually likes the news Sam
Sam's into the news dude I I read the
news like crazy you don't read the news
I'm an anti-newser
I just love drama
you know Preppers I'm like whatever that
is where you avoid the news at all costs
yeah I just like gossip I'm a big fan of
drama my life's pretty boring so I I
need I need drama I love the comment
sections too somebody said this the
other day I think it was like Nepal or
one of these smart guys they go um
the goal of the media is to make every
problem your problem
go that's pretty true that's kind of
like what the news is it's like oh
there's a flood in this County I don't
live in [__] let me watch this for 20
minutes why do I care about this this
has nothing to do with me all right but
anyways sorry let's start with the most
interesting one Ben what is it we're
starting a little close to home uh your
friend Nikita beer uh his social app gas
was acquired by Discord for an
undisclosed amount what do you guys
think about your buddy Nikita being
acquired by Discord
give the background Sean about this guy
like because it's a pretty he it's a
caper I call this a caper
you know what that means
no a caper it's like a uh a scheme but
like uh it's like when you would rob a
bank you know you'd be like what's that
great Caper fool me once shame on you
fool me twice shame on me he just fooled
the tech industry twice dude he sold the
same app so he built an app called TBH
that was like uh you know let a teenager
go on and it basically quiz you about
people in your school your friends and
be like who's the most cute boy in your
life and you're like oh Sam it's like
who's the most likely to be famous oh
it's Ben right where you just do that
right and then they would and just like
it was eight years ago yeah download my
app and of course that [__] worked he
did that and like it immediately went
viral because it went viral Facebook
buys the thing because Facebook has like
a system internally that says like viral
Team app and then it's like must acquire
must acquire viral teenage app you know
I get that young blood in here and so
they acquired it
people had said 100 million dollars I
don't it's not 100 million dollars uh
but but I think something more like 30
40 million bucks and um
and this was in 2017
2017. he sells the app
promptly the app gets shut down within
like a year because there was never any
retention in this app
he then sits at Facebook for four years
and vests out the entire every cent of
his earn out which is just hilarious in
its own right
um and all he did was just tweet all day
you know like you know he worked in the
new products division and uh you know
half released some apps I guess and then
he he leaves you know what's it called
recidivism Sam you're yeah you're a
person guy he leaves the jail of
Facebook
and he does the same goddamn thing again
he creates another teen app for
compliments he tells us this in advance
he goes yeah I'm gonna I'm just gonna
make an app that makes like uh 10
million dollars in three months
and we both kind of laughed it off and
we're like is that even possible
and then he pretty much did it I think
gas app has made 7 million in gross
sales in like
three-ish months so you know pretty much
called his shot which we do respect but
also
we have to clarify one thing Sam Ben
said he's our friend is he still our
friend after how insufferable he is in
the group chat
so he is insufferable but I kind of like
it a little bit uh I think it's pretty
hilarious I love a good troll I think
that you're missing some of the data
here so he sold the company to Discord
there's no release on price or anything
like that but uh some people can make
guesses but basically between leaving or
being at Facebook and Discord he creates
this Mystique I call him the Jewish
Great Gatsby he creates this kind of
Mystique where he's got this really
lovely home in La I he's single or at
least he's not married and he like hosts
really fun parties and then he posts on
Twitter about like his opinion on going
viral and all like Legends likes or
quote Legends start following him and
they like message him and they he's
created this Aura of sophistication and
of like he knows what he's doing with
apps which is true it's all true he's
very talented but it was pretty cool how
it was like kind of systematic so he has
the talent he has the skill but he great
job of also flexing that he had the
talent and he had the skill and people
start flocking to him and when he starts
launching this thing and here's the
analogy he's like he's like the guy who
Moved he moved to a new high school as a
sophomore
and then didn't try to make a single
friend but he just went to lunch and he
was just totally content sitting by
himself he wasn't a loser he was almost
too cool to have to try and because of
that everyone's like who is this guy
does he have a is his girlfriend in
college oh my God
and he would just be like you know
texting his college girlfriend that you
don't know if you know if they exist but
he just built this Aura this Mystique
around him by almost not trying whereas
everybody else on Twitter is like hey
follow me for more threads about how
great I am right and he's he's trying to
do the exact opposite where he's just
like only [__] posting and um you know
just hinting and posting little
screenshots that make you think he's up
to something big at all times yeah
you're like who's this kid coming up to
school as a 16 year old in a motorcycle
you know like this guy's got a neck
tattoo like I can't confirm that he's a
badass but like all all sides point to
it that that was his thing and he never
he didn't deny it he didn't confirm it
so it could be true it could not be true
but the fact is is that he created this
app something happened to it like
there's a crazy rumor with the app that
it was used for child sex trafficking
which wasn't true he changed the name of
the app then he changed the name again a
third time and it takes off and he sells
it uh we're recording this on a
Wednesday I believe it was announced
yesterday this is a wonderful Caper not
to say that Discord didn't get value I
have no idea what the truth is uh the
truth is probably like they're gonna
make something cool of it who knows but
he pulled it off he called the shot he
pulled it off and he did it in such an
obnoxious way and that's how I love him
you know I love guys like that I love
what he did
and honestly I love the way he did it
too but the problem is he's like a fart
a fart is amazing when you're more than
six feet away but you don't want to be
too close to the fart like you know the
fart's not funny when you're right up
against it and so that's the problem
with this is if we were too close to it
we got we had to hear him and he loves
smelling his own scent I love smelling
his own fart too and so you know he will
in our group chat just post every like
Twitter mention where somebody's like oh
my God Nikita has done it again
Nikita is the best it's like bro I don't
need your Twitter mentions posted here
uh you know for me for me to see uh it
is completely he's an insufferable fart
but I do respect what he's pulled off
yeah it's pretty funny so this is like
an interesting thing I can't believe he
pulled it off but he called his shot I
respect that I think it's cool also he's
done a thing like you know um Mr Beast
does this thing where like if you go
talk to a pretty serious business person
they'll like reference Mr Beast like a
Mr Beast ISM where they're like um well
Mr B said uh yeah yeah Jimmy just says
you know we just try to make great
videos
as if like nobody else tries to make
great videos or he'll be like uh or
he'll be like you know we just um we're
willing to put more into our content
trying to make the best content possible
blah blah it's like and then if somebody
goes and looks and they're like bro you
you your your video is put your hand on
this car and the last person to take
their hand off you know the last person
with their hand on the car keeps the car
like this is not like you know you're
not stupid Spielberg over here but
didn't we talk about this where we're
like look we're gonna do this thing and
we're gonna send them a welcome letter
and we're just gonna make it really
delightful it's just gonna be a
beautiful totally well done just
beautifully done and if you do it like
that people start to buy in they start
to eat that little puppy chow and so
similarly he um Mr Beast does this
reality Distortion where he makes you
believe that he is the deepest thinker
he's creating the most epic beautiful
well done content he is really
thoughtful it's just so it's like you
know watch me fart in people's ears
it's true that people I'm on a fart kick
today people
um people do like it the content
definitely works but it creates this
almost this Mystique around it and I
feel like Nikita did the same thing
where he'll tweet out [__] where he'll
be like um
just move the butthole a Little Closer
let's read out like uh you know the you
know um the underrated metric and social
networking is density uh by far more
important than spread and he's like you
know like if you're still measuring K
Factor you might as well still be using
a Blackberry right and he was like no
three that [__] that makes you think
like damn this this [__] knows
[__] that I don't know about social
networking I would be like there's only
five people on Earth that can tell you
about building social networks the
problem is they're all unhirable because
their name are names are Mark Zuckerberg
Jack Dorsey and Nikita here
so and and so by the way I I think
there's levels to this there's levels so
I think he does a great job of creating
it's like bro you created a app that
lets me say which which girl in my high
school is the cutest and then it texts
her somebody said you're cute right like
yeah it there's Beauty in the Simplicity
for sure but they almost make it sound
more complicated and artistic than it
really is and uh and trust me it's not
we're not we're not like every other
social app you see we're changing the
world one popularity contest at a time
we are we're democratizing popularity he
went on um on like CNBC or one of these
like reduced networks or whatever and
they were like we have here the founder
of the hit teen app The Sensational app
yes
Nikita
what inspired you to do this and he's
like you know we just believe that teens
you know the world needed a little more
positivity and that uh we wanted to
create a safe space for whatever dude
the only safe space he wanted was it was
a vacation home in in time
you want to do you know you you wanted
to fly private hey
boys that that is amazing yeah his next
app is gonna be called plebe
uh but in all seriousness he pulled it
off I think it's cool uh yeah I make fun
of him because uh because of how
obnoxious he's been for four months on
this group chat but uh but you know deep
down uh he's my kind of people I respect
uh I respect what he's done and I also
respect the massive troll that he's
played on everybody here so this is good
speaking of trolls who didn't pull it
off uh Ben we got to get to the next
story before we get to the next story
though we do have to remind everyone we
have a gentleman's agreement here
everyone follows it if you follow if you
listen to us it doesn't matter what app
you're listening to you have to go to
our YouTube page and you click subscribe
that's the gentleman's agreement I have
my pen here am I going to need this for
the gentleman's agreement do I need to
sign something or what do I do you
actually don't see all you have to do is
go to our YouTube page and you click
subscribe you don't even need a pen
that's how easy it is we made this
Gentleman's Agreement incredibly simple
you go and you subscribe and then we
work for you and we make this content
for you and we reveal our life and
dedicate Our Lives to you it's simple
that's the gentleman's agreement
I can't find this client info have you
heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow better
next topic
from someone who pulled off the caper to
someone who did not JPMorgan Chase
bought College financial aid platform
Frank for 175 million dollars it has now
shut down the website and claims that
they fabricated more than 4 million
accounts on their first email to their
customer list they got a 70 bounce back
uh founder Charlie Javis I think it's
pronounced denies that this is fraud and
claims that JP Morgan is just inventing
reasons to not pay her fellas boys who
do you believe well JP Morgan this lady
was on uh like that's easy uh this lady
was a Forbes 30 under 30 and then just
like a couple years later sells her app
for nine nine figures 100 million plus
and uh it's pretty hilarious they even
found they tracked it down I believe
where they talked to the developers it
was a it was like a they hired one
freelancer I think who they said hey can
you like make some test data to put in
here and he starts doing it and they're
the the guy was like I think this is
fraud I'm out so they found those emails
and then they did it again with another
contractor and who actually did do it
and they convinced the contractor that
it wasn't fraud and so they've kind of
like honed in on this that it seems
quite clear that it's fraud uh
bold move very bold move very easy to
catch though really stupid like this
seems like really a foolish mistake
yeah this is like um
JP Morgan's got a little egg on their
face for not noticing this because this
is pretty easy to notice I mean the fact
that they sent one email and 70 bounced
back right like that that sounds uh like
it wasn't this really sophisticated you
know botnet that you know was simulating
real users it was just a bunch of fake
fake emails in a uh uh you know in a
database so you know that sounds pretty
easy and also it says Uh there's there's
an email with her she's asking the
professor who ended up doing this will
the will the fake emails look real with
an eye check or is it better to use
unique ID right so like
you know
handed the cookie jar as we say around
here that means you got caught okay you
got got and okay I think we should
create a set of the Forbes 30 under 30.
I think we need like the Madoff 1000
um we're all the grifters and con
artists that are that are out there
um you know I I think that you know
maybe the Caper Caper 20 or something
like that we got to come up with
something here and we need to just
annually I think we should just do a
show but we just rank the best cons of
the year and uh and give them their due
let them put that on their bio dude I'm
down and what's crazy is this is so so
when I sold the hustle we had I think
1.7 million subscribers we used this
service HubSpot paid for it and it was a
service I forget the name of it but I
believe it did two things we uploaded
our whole email list and then I think
HubSpot uploaded some of their email I
don't remember exactly how it worked I
think they did it and it showed the
crossover like how many we each shared
in a huge amount of emails I imagine
HubSpot has like hundreds of millions I
have no idea a lot of emails and then I
also think it checked for fraud and it
was like a couple days to do this it was
pretty simple
um there's just a few other services
where they make fake data and the reason
they do this is if you have a sensitive
thing like a bank startup you put a
whole bunch of fake data in it and it
like makes up people and you can test
your data because you can't use like you
know obviously real Social Security
numbers when you're testing certain
things and they would make up fake stuff
just to test the software make sure it
all works Sonic I think it's called
tonic.ai it's the and then says the fake
data company we talked about them on the
Pod I love this idea I've been trying to
invest yeah I forgot I need to invest in
this yeah I think it's a cool thing and
so also with gpt3 whatever it's called I
was like thinking I'm like dude I should
just I'm not gonna do this but maybe I I
was like I should just make up fake fake
reviews for all of my like products and
you could just like make up fake reviews
or you could like make up negative
reviews for all your competitors
products but uh and I was like are you
looking for a nomination to the Madoff
1000 we'd be happy to have you
but you do need to formally submit the
application in yeah and we have to make
everyone pay a a 500 application fee too
if there's no con going on on our side
what are we doing here yeah yeah yeah
yeah well don't you want to win the
award it's an award yeah you did a thing
with milk Road where um we have this
philosophy which is like
we should be we should bank that in the
future we're going to cut out all
advertisers and be our own Advertiser I
mean only promote our own product our
own service in this newsletter
um that's the only way to hold yourself
like accountable to not just acquiring
like shitty subscribers right and so we
we had started this new growth Channel
we're like oh let's try this thing out
we heard there you know the rates are
pretty good we tried it out
uh we tried it for like a week and we're
like oh the numbers look pretty good
we're getting cheap signups they're
opening the email that sounds great and
I was like hey just you know just for
just to double check here why don't you
just email all those people that signed
up and um just ask them like you know a
simple question like you know hey like
ask them a one-line question that would
be quick video you're in for them to
answer just be like hey I just wanted to
know blah blah blah I'm the founder of
this thing just wanted to know blank uh
because they're opening the thing daily
it looks like okay fantastic surely they
would they would reply to an email from
the owner of the thing they read every
day right
um and he was like dude guess how many I
forgot how many there was like a couple
thousand people on this thing he was
like guess how many people replied
I was like well you didn't say
percentage so man this is a number of
people who replied I was like I don't
know like 400 500 and he was like two we
got two replies turned off the channel
oh my God I was like Wow and I know a
bunch of other people that are still
buying from this trap this like you know
this uh this marketing player this
traffic source and I'm like well they're
they're just dumping money down the
drain if they're doing that dude seeing
uh Billy McFarlane and the thranos lady
go to jail
um like this woman potentially could go
to jail it's pretty crazy that like
what
do they not think like just like eight
months in advance it's like man this
isn't like internet play games this is
like go to prison games you're this is
really screwing up a a hundred plus
million dollar acquisition and 70 of the
users were fake that is crazy you go to
prison for that type of stuff that is
wild and it's just crazy to think that
no one's there and they're like uh
Charlie
um you know like are you do you like
generic Oreos and bologna sandwiches if
yes then this is great because that's
what you're gonna be eating for like the
next nine months in prison
Oreos that's that's nice well not not
when it's every day and watered down
Kool-Aid but like it's just it's it's
pretty wild that people don't think
ahead but uh this is such an obvious
scam also JP Morgan you guys suck man
you guys gotta be on top of the ball
like this is such a this seems pretty
easy to to figure out yeah fair enough
all right what's what's next
all right
um Bitcoin and ethereum are up 23 over
the last week uh crypto's rallying uh
one major cause is continued rise of
inflation 6.5 annualized in December the
question for you fellas is crypto back
no
you want to just end it there
I don't know well I will give you
that's a great answer Sam
[Laughter]
um I get to say like I told you so no I
don't get to say I told you so yeah in
fact I might maybe take the other the
other L did I did I sell book road too
early did I sell the bottom
um
no I I think that a lot of things are
rallying right now why because people
did I think it's just a simple answer
people did an end-of-year sell-off in
December for tax loss harvesting and a
lot of people will re-enter and then
that creates some upward momentum and
when there's upward momentum that makes
people think hey is it coming back is
this the rally uh did we do we hit the
bottom is it time to buy back in and so
people are buying back in
um I don't think it's because inflation
in December because guess what we had
inflation in October and November and
September and August too like where
where was you know if if inflation was
driving crypto up it should have been up
all year last year not uh not down and
so I don't think that that narrative
holds I think it's much more likely that
the same way that tech stocks are having
a little brief rally
um it's uh it's kind of like New Year
optimism uh people being done with their
kind of like in crypto there's no wash
sale rules so you could sell book the
loss for tax purposes and buy back in
one minute later uh if you wanted to and
so I think people are just buying back
in and I think there's a little bit of
people chasing momentum that's my guess
have you ever looked at the correlation
between G-Wagon prices use Rolex market
and Miami penthouses and how it relates
to crypto
did you see uh yeah Ben Google that did
you see uh uh I'm just gonna start
telling Ben just in Google random stuff
that are ungoogleable uh did you see
that there was a guy in like you know
how we have this Facebook group for MFM
that we don't really check often but
there was a guy who was like posting in
a bunch and he created this website
where you can sell your nft at a loss
for tax purposes it's kind of
interesting it was a great idea honestly
um what's it called I forgot I'm gonna
forget the name uh Ben might actually
know it um it was called they advertised
in the milk road so I remember seeing it
there and being like oh wow this is
actually a great idea hold on chat what
did you say it was like a really it was
like a white guy with like blonde hair
looks like unsellable what is it
unsellable nfts yeah yeah that's it
unsellable nfts and so basically
um if you wanted to book a a loss on
your nft they would basically let you
instantly get liquid on it and get it
right back I think is the is the idea
um
which is just a very useful simple tool
so you know get on that guy for creating
that that was a smart smart idea
so is this the segment Dem boys Dem boys
react is that it
I think I think we're not from Dem boys
yeah
I think we're still the boys until until
we get a little more street cred go to
the YouTube comments and tell us is the
boys gonna stick can I make it a thing
because I sure sure would like that yeah
just type it as a thing or not a thing
in the comments I just wanna I'll do
I'll read the poll and if it says not a
thing I'll only continue for another
three or four years if it says it's a
thing I'm totally validated all right
that's it
[Music]
foreign